[Music]
hello everyone welcome to P einhoven
2023 we are here in this high-tech
campus where we've had over two Keynotes
25 speakers we had 40 volunteers helping
out we had over 90 proposals coming in
and we had actually over 350 people
joining this wonderful event hi my name
is Max I'm from CB data I over today we
are at P data I over
2023 our goal today is to share
knowledge and to connect with every date
in the chest here in the region hey I'm
Sebastian I'm a principal data scientist
with thoughtworks we're here at P data
in an Hoven to connect with the
community that use uses uh python to
make great things with data this is
exactly what we do at thoughtworks every
single day so connecting with these
people is exactly why we're here here
what are you here personally I'm here to
meet new people make some friends share
some knowledge um see what's going on
there and kind of step out of my bble uh
and see some new things get inspired
yeah that's why I'm here and it's lots
of fun and hope to see you again
sometime in the
[Music]
future